there are certain questions that I'm
asked a lot people will say which of the
movies that were made out of your books
do you like they'll ask me probably the
most common one is where do you get your
ideas and it's to me it if you ask me
that specifically
I can tell you about 50 percent of the
time where I got the ideas and the rest
of it is totally it's like getting an
idea in a dream and I can't really
remember where they came from sometimes
I can sometimes I can't but to talk a
little bit about the process the way
that it works for me and it might not
work that way for you but this is the
way it works for me I want to talk a
little bit about what I'm working on now
which is a novel that's about 3/4 done
and if I'm very very lucky it will get
finished but no more like Tuesday
because no actually I'd love to get it
done by the end of the year and I'm
really driving on this thing now and
once I start to really drive it usually
goes fairly fast but I never know if a
books gonna get done until it's done
because I don't plot I don't keep much
in the way of notes probably more than I
used to because I'm older and that's
what happens your gears start to slip a
little bit but one of the one of the
worst things that I ever heard for me
personally was I did something with John
Irving one time and he said that when
he's starting a book the first thing he
does is write the last line and I
thought to myself Jesus Christ that's
like eating the frosting off your cake
and then eating your cake I just to me I
didn't see it but he knows everything
that's going to happen and I know really
fuck-all what's going to happen
I'm telling you the truth sit there but
here's here's the way this works for me
when I was driving up from Florida to
Maine last year because I always drive
back and forth I stopped the first night
in South Carolina and I stayed at Adam
Hotel Motel 6 or something like that and
you know there's really not anything to
do there but turn on the TV and kick
back and watch the local news and
whatever else happens to be on so I
turned on the TV and those the local
news and they had this story and the
story was about something that had
happened at McDonald's the McDonald's do
you know this was like a year ago the
economy still really just absolutely
wretched and so McDonald's announced
that they were hiring in this town it
might have been Charleston I'm not sure
but all these people turned up doing
like a thousand people that turned up to
apply for jobs and there was one woman
in this bunch of people that was waiting
to try to get a job who had had a fight
with another woman
the day before the first woman was
married to this guy she caught the woman
who was applying for a job in McDonald's
in bed with her husband she got wicked
pissed
and she decided that she was going to
confront this woman you know and
basically rip her hair off if that was
possible so she got in her car she found
out that the woman was applying for a
job at McDonald's and she drove there
and she got out of the car pushed away
through all these job applicants and
grabbed this woman and started to shake
her they had a fight the woman who was
applying for a job broke away and
disappeared into the car into the crowd
so the woman who had come there got back
into her car put it in gear and drove
into the job seekers they just went
everywhere there was cellphone footage
of it she got the woman pasted her a
couple of good ones got back into her
car threw it in reverse and backed over
a bunch more people on her way out when
two people were killed and I thought to
myself I want to write about this I
didn't know why I wanted to write about
it or what I wanted to write about it I
just knew that I wanted to write about
it now some people what I'm in a group
like this and I'm not going to stand
stand behind this goddamn lecturing the
whole time because it feels weird like a
presidential debate or something but
people will say do you keep a notebook
and the answer is I think a writer's
notebook is the best way in the world to
immortalize bad ideas my idea about a
good idea is one that sticks around and
sticks around and sticks around it's
like to me it's like if you were to put
bread crumbs in a strainer and shake it
which is what the passage of time is for
me it's like shaking a strainer all this
stuff that's not very big and not very
important just kind of dissolves and
falls out but the good stuff stays you
know the big pieces stay I had the idea
for under the dome when I was teaching
high school back in 1973 and it was just
too big for me and I was too young for
it and I wrote about 25 26 pages and put
it away does it sing it at the beginning
of this book where this woodchuck gets
cut in half
this dome comes down over this town I
had written that part when I was in in
my early 20s and just sort of recreated
it from memory when I when I wrote the
book so the good stuff stays so I saw
this thing and I wanted to write about
it and this goes
illy Rees not even talking about this
was because Andre was saying you when
you wrote Tony
you started to write about baseball and
it just sort of grew well this thing
stuck around it and then my method for
starting anything is I tell myself the
story when I'm laying in bed at night
before I go to sleep I'll tell myself
this story and so at some point probably
nine months after this because this is
what it's like you know a little piece
of grit and it makes a pearl after a
while you just have to give it time and
if it doesn't have it it doesn't but a
lot of times it does so about nine
months after that I thought well what if
a guy did this and did it on purpose and
he killed a bunch of people and what if
there was a detective that was sort of
at the end of his working career and
this was like a detective who'd had a
lot of success with a lot of cases but
he didn't have time to do much with this
one because of mandatory retirement so
what if after a while the guy who did it
wrote him a letter and said I did it I'm
really glad I did it
I enjoyed the screams I heard their
bones breaking as this car went over
them I just absolutely adored the whole
experience of killing all these people
the blood went up on the windshield the
headlights broke you know I was wearing
a mask so I knew that they wouldn't know
who I was I didn't know if I would get
away with it but I did I did and it was
great and here's the thing this guy's
saying in this letter a lot of times
guys like me they do something like this
and if the cops don't catch him right
away they say well wait he'll try to do
it again and we'll catch him then but
guess what I don't want to do it again
once was enough I just relived the
memories and you know it's a really mmm
I was working this letter over in my
mind and a really nasty piece of work
you know but the thing was what made it
nasty these things all tied down come on
Jesus Christ what fun is that so what
I'm thinking is the cop you know I you
know this thing about blue suicide and
you cops retire and they get you know
they don't have anything else to do and
a lot of them eat their own gun and I
thought here's this cop who's sitting in
his house and he gets this letter about
six months after he's retired the only
thing he's done is watch daytime TV
you know like Judge Judy and dr. Phil I
mean that would drive me to suicide
right there so oh yeah you laugh like
you never [ __ ] watch their show right
that's right you know what I did I got
in about 11 o'clock to this thing and
the first thing I did was turn on The
Price is Right okay and I got just in
time for the big jackpot thing at the
end and I'm guessing right along with
them so I'm no better and I don't I
don't pretend to be but anyway I thought
to myself this is going to be a short
story that's the only thing I was
thinking is I'm going to tell it in the
present tense it's going to be this cop
he's going to get this letter he's going
to realize he can never solve this and
at the end of the letter which I was
going to save for the end the guy was
going to say I know you've still got
your service weapon and you're never
going to catch me so you might as well
use it
and I wanted to end the story with the
guy putting the gun into his mouth so
now instead of a 12-page story I've got
a 500 page manuscript because the thing
just grew and that's the way it works
for me I don't try to force them to be
anything that they don't want to be